all right we got the story from the
National Review the American people won
Biden celebrates inflation reduction act
as Market plummets over August inflation
news so I don't know if they have photos
but you get all they have all these
people celebrating on the White House
lawn they're like the inflation
reduction act we did it meanwhile
everybody else in the internet is like
oh take a look at that oh what is that
Finn Finn twit what is this all things
Finance tweets this is not a
cryptocurrency it's the U.S stock
markets oh man and I don't even think
that's the worst that just shows like a
hundred Point fall off the story from
MarketWatch is the Dow Jones books near
1300 Point drop as stocks record worst
day since June 2022. so Bravo Joe Biden
he's celebrating as everything's burning
down around this reminds me that George
Bush
um mission accomplished meme where he
stand on the aircraft carrier it's like
day three after the war on terror begins
and of course it went on for 20 years
this is a good one that Luke posted oh
yeah I saw that one I couldn't resist
reposting it but but another thing we
should really consider here is that a
stock market is not the real kind of
effect of economy the stock market is of
artificially inflated with the Federal
Reserve printing money and giving it to
many of these Wall Street companies so
even with the bailouts that were
secretly given by the Federal Reserve to
Wall Street we are still seeing
extremely negative impacts and what
we're seeing on the streets of the
United States is way worse than what
we're seeing on Wall Street and these
numbers 8.3 percent I mean that's
nothing compared to what you see out
there in the real world what you see out
there in the grocery stores and what you
see out there with people and their rent
yeah Ian brought something up before the
show because we often talk about where
all the workers at and then Ian was like
they're homeless the homeless population
is exploding right now at least for from
what I've been learning about Los
Angeles you're from Los Angeles it's
massive out there I've been there my
whole life in the suburbs of Los Angeles
or in Los Angeles and I was just telling
you guys I was saying earlier that we
went to a play recently and we got off
the freeway first thing person we see is
a naked person standing on a corner uh
you know her breasts and I was I was
stunned how bad the Homeless Problem had
gotten in Los Angeles and it's and it's
more than just the weather Florida
doesn't have the same issue I think it's
a lot of it has a lot to do with the
ideology a lot to do with the rehab
centers you know uh infiltrate excuse me
using Obamacare and loopholes and
ObamaCare to bring patients out but it's
just gotten to a point where people just
step over it now they don't even think
much about it and it's it's a it's a sad
state of being if you go over to the VA
area over by UCLA and this is like one
of the richest enclaves of Los Angeles
it's right there in Beverly Hills and
just tent after tent just going down
this street outside the VA and Los
Angeles the launched Los Angeles crowd
just doesn't care much about it they
just they look the other way even here I
was in town today we don't have a big
town where we live which town There's a
couple uh the one West Virginia yeah in
West Virginia and Charleston yeah and
and there's a homeless guy there yep I
never seen a homeless guy there but but
he had a sign saying I don't want your
money I want a job
um so so seeing stuff like that seeing
people impacted it so horribly so
negatively and these people are
celebrating these people are giving
Victory speeches these people are having
musicians come to the White House lawn
and and play music and and act like they
did something great for the people it's
just such a smack in the face for anyone
yeah they live in a bubble it's I was
thinking this Jackson Mississippi Water
Crisis is like should be number one news
in the world or at least in the United
States right now like a city one of our
greatest cities or largest cities has no
drinking water they're on like a boil
your water alert right now and it could
very well still be toxic
um maybe the economy the inflation is
probably the biggest story but this what
that people are just like have somewhat
of a blind eye towards the fact that a
city is struggling to have drinking
water have you seen the running water
that they've been opening up on that
it's like comes out black and brown you
know to touch on your mission
accomplished uh comment I think they
they know they can do this because they
don't have control of the uh they have
control I should say of the narrative
machine the Biden and them know that
Hollywood's not going to come at them
the media is not going to come at them
this entire narrative machine is not
going to call them out the same way that
they did with Mission Impossible I
remember that time at Mission Impossible
and uh Bush got raped over the quick up
pulled over the coals on that for that
comment you're not going to see this
happen with Biden because they do not
have the same kind of pushback this is
why we see the Democrats can be so much
more corrupt than the Republicans
because they they have checks and
balances on the Republicans through the
media through Hollywood through the
literary industry and what have you so
it I think that's part of the reason why
conservatives need to really and the
right or anyone from the anti-woke world
needs to get into the culture game and
start creating these institutions like
what you're doing now what you're doing
with music I really I applaud you guys
for getting into this coaching and
talking about culture all the time and
creating the content because otherwise
they're just going to keep getting
getting away with this guy yeah I think
about waking up and looking at Twitter
like what happened today as opposed to
waking up and making something and and
being like this is what happened because
I made it happen like getting up and
looking around at like what's going on
it's kind of like a reactionary way to
live and it's we're really in a place
where we need to create what's happening
this is important too that you do need
to talk about things the media aspect is
very very important but on top of that
the next layer is creating content
creating these culture movements if you
look at back at movies like Jerry
Maguire for example I love this this
movie okay everybody saw it there's this
moment where Jerry Maguire is drunk and
he grabs his assistant and he he
re-kiels knowing that what he did was
wrong and he says oh I'm Clarence Thomas
now oh my God I'm Clarence Thomas now
I'm Clarence Thomas now they put those
kinds of messages in all of their
content and all of their movies and all
their TVs just scene by scene Story by
story painting the other side in a
certain way and and so I think that's
why it's so important for us to get in
this game because we need to be able to
push back on these people when they
Gaslight us on things like this
inflation this inflation act shout out
to Tom McDonald song Riot if you guys
haven't listened to it already check it
out uh download it on iTunes and check
it out on Spotify because Tom's one of
the leaders in anti-establishment he's
independent he's producing his own media
this latest song is basically about him
just like saying screw off to the The
Establishment and so I dig it and I'm
and I wanted to shout him out because
you're completely right about winning a
culture War you need culture 100 it's
what defines what it means to be America
American right Hollywood has been
defining that for decades and decades
we've won Wars politically and and this
is the difference between I think the
right and the left the left thinks about
success in decades the right thinks
about success in election cycles and
we're always talking about two years
ahead two years ahead two years ahead
where the left is talking 10 20 30 years
ahead they are soaking in the seeds that
they planted back in the 40s and 50s and
60s right now we're at this culture that
we're seeing right now that infiltrate
that took over 2020 in the summer of
riots didn't just happen overnight
they've been pushing this message out
there through their music and through
their films and through their television
shows for years that the Republicans are
racist that the that their rights are
homophobes that the rights are you know
womanizers and what have you they've
been doing that for decades but for what
reason right so some people think it's
like a bigger conspiracy you know
Marxist infiltrated the country or
something like that or I wonder if it's
just a cult chasing itself into you know
a spiral it is 100 a cold we were in the
belly of the Beast for about 10 years
our daughter went to this really
prestigious private school we were
around Studio heads Hollywood studio
heads Big actors Jason Bateman Melissa
McCartney had a kid in our class
Scott what's his name that's uh that's
on this new series anyways a bunch of
bunch of celebrities and we noticed very
early on that it was a cult there that
they were this very insulated group that
and there's this one moment where we
caught this guy you're not going to
believe this guys we caught this guy
getting in bed with other people's kids
what okay what five six seven-year-old
kids the entire community of the school
was behind us on us we called him out we
said what are you doing this is
dangerous this is at the very least it's
unsafe
um and uh you know he came at us and
said he was going to sue us connected to
a billion dollar family we said we're
not backing down there's nothing that
you can say that's going to stop us from
from calling you out on this the entire
Hollywood Community was behind us in
this group in this school and he was
smart what he said was they're
Republicans these guys are Republicans
that are calling me out overnight this
entire Community turned on us wow and
that's the the perfect example of a cult
where there's certain kinds of groups
that it just have to be shunned from the
group and that's exactly what they did
it was a fascinating uh experience to
watch did the guy keep sleeping in a bed
with kids after he stopped he actually
got it in writing from him that he was
going to stop um doing what was
upsetting us he wouldn't admit to that
but we we laid it out in line items you
did this you did this with four or five
different games I wouldn't trust the
writing I would just send them to jail
well when you when you're in these
communities that you can get away with
these kinds of things because they have
their billion dollar families and they
they I think I'm I'm convinced after
this experience that that kind of thing
happens more often there than anywhere
else but it also shows this kind of
sexualization of kids it's coming out
from these communities it's coming out
they're the big pushers years behind a
lot of this kind of sexualization of
kids out of this community we see it in
their television shows we see it in
their writing they they control the
cultural blueprint through their screen
right yeah you see that uh what's her
name Jeanette McCurdy was that the
actress a young actress yeah there's
these like she wrote a book about the
weird abuse someone made a video
compilation from her her show or just
Disney shows in general and there's this
weird stuff where like they have little
girls feet and they're like rubbing
ketchup on it and stuff like just really
creepy stuff you see that stuff in
cartoons all the time I just saw a meme
right now for a Shrek movie and they
were they literally had a meme where
there was a very sexual thing just for a
split second you could see it they're
constantly embedding these kinds of
things thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there